what is the best Dark Souls mod you can
imagine is it something that changes the
level design adding new architecture
shortcuts and platforms or is it
something that rebalances the existing
game adding a ton of cut contents
weapons armor and spells yeah but what
about a mod that dramatically changes
your core experience with these
incredible changes to progression bosses
and law there are three souls games on
PC and each one of them actually has a
mod that sort of stands above the rest
these overhaul the entire experience and
we streamed all of them over twitch.tv
slash party video so go and follow so
that you too can be one of the people
laughing at me in the children jumping
across these platforms was how I decided
to spend four full hours in my dark
cells to stream the mod or go
of darkness is special in that it adds
completely new explorable terrain to the
game particularly in AIDS terror of
flame which features these natural
extensions of the level new enemies and
this totally fair and totally rewarding
jumping puzzle but we persevered and we
claimed our reward we persevered and
claimed our reward if you're like me
you've probably completed these games so
many times that you just kind of run
past everything but all it really takes
is one little wall or putting millenia
in a random corner of the map before
you're forced to explore everything
again and when you're forced to explore
everything again you realize they've
changed stuff in the places that you
wouldn't usually explore and before you
know it you're playing like this is your
first Souls game lost and confused and
excited whenever you pick up a new item
sometimes too excited cruises fire
defense and that's plus one as well so
now I can actually walk right into these
flames
I meant to just touch them like what I
walked past
I mean areas beyond hates tower are
different but I will say that I noticed
that the further I went in this mod the
less was changed of all the mods on this
list though this is the one with the
most potential the ability to add to and
change the geography of the level here
is groundbreaking literally and there
are other models who are using these
same tools as we speak to overhaul the
experience of Dark Souls 2 even further
keep an eye on stay 3d on Twitter who is
doing something similar to this and
thank you to vampire the mods creator
for all of the hard work on the augur of
darkness mod for Dark Souls 2 links to
these mods are in the description next
up the cinders mod for Dark Souls 3 by
silo see if you're the kind of person
who got upset that sekito
only used one katana the entire game
then this is the mod for you build
variety is improved tenfold by this mod
and the result is this way more diverse
immersive experience an absurd amount of
equipment has been added in this mod
with models and animations pulled from
every Souls game from Demon Souls to
blood-borne as well and this includes
cut content some weapons even have
completely unique weapon arts like the
crab claw that shoots bubbles
and some have passive effects as well
that just make a lot of sense the best
example is the beasts claws from
blood-borne here scaling in damage with
every hit you deal
additionally there are new embers and
weapon modifications that you can try
and every upgrade path that you take
includes a unique passive effect seen on
screen in general weapon damage has been
rebalanced which is all some weapons
needed to be completely viable for
example I recommend you try out a ranger
build with the short bow now which can
actually be used as a main weapon but
who needs weapons to kill enemies really
yeah that's a great place to heal it's
totally gonna go fine for you the world
now has way more of these unique NPC
enemies and pretty much every one of
them is wielding a unique weapon that
they're almost guaranteed to drop
they're not always as easy to kill as
that guy was though some are far more
intimidating like this baby pursuer one
thing I'm excited to try in my next
playthrough and honestly one thing I've
wanted to be a thing in every souls game
is like a tanky battle mage build and
there's so many reasons to try a magic
build like this staffs actually do good
melee damage now in this mod and then
move sets have been massively improved
furthermore your focus regenerates
passively at a really good rate and once
you've tried the game like this you
realize that regenerating mana focus is
how it should have worked in the base
game and the spells did I mention the
spells there's so many new ones and to
spice up the boss fights as well their
music has been replaced with Alex Rose
famous Dark Souls remixes and while most
of the fights are the same some of them
you do have to approach in entirely
different ways and the order you
progress through many of these places
has been tweaked as well
but if it's changes to progression and
to bosses that you want then nothing
compares to the daughters of Ashmont for
Dark Souls and it is my favorite mod on
this list it's so good
I currently tell you how good it is
because I'll spoil all the amazing putts
but bear with me this mod excels in a
few key areas
first there's progression because the
level design of the original Dark Souls
is just God Tyr and it's so intertwined
the mod creator actually has a lot of
flexibility in how they can serve levels
to you an excellent example of this is
how you approach Blighttown so normally
you go through black town by going
through the parish then the depths then
descending the rickety parts of
Blighttown
but in this mod you go the opposite way
you unlock the door under fire link you
take the elevator down to the swamp and
in order to get back up you have to
traverse Blighttown backwards which is
an experience that I don't exactly want
to repeat but it's one that was
memorable to say the least the whole mod
from start to finish is like this and it
makes you feel as lost and engaged as
you were in your first blind playthrough
of the original game next no mod does
boss encounters better than this one
there's this one boss that invades you
and then chases you through the world
until you kill it there's a boss that
steals the ability to walk between
bonfires from you until you track him
down on foot and steal it back there are
bosses with tweaks to their attack speed
that messes with your muscle memory and
the addition of extra enemies in these
fights is tasteful and really respectful
of the law and you'd better respect the
law you know it's important because
sometimes you should read what happens
when you remove certain rings for
example that ring I removed was this
special covenant ring that you can
choose as a gift and it allows you to
choose from a set of buffs and debuffs
at the start of the game that can make
your playthrough more interesting you
really should read through the item
descriptions in this mod not just
because it'll save your life but also
because the mods creator is also an
excellent writer from what
and they've tastefully expanded the law
of the original game there's even a good
amount of realism added regarding the
weapons you use a blunt weapon will do
way way more damage against the iron
golem for example so consider your
weapon types and consider what you're
hitting and keep a few favoured weapons
on hand
honestly this mod just reinforces why I
do think Dark Souls is still the best of
three souls games it builds upon that
excellent foundation that the first game
has and there's so much you can do with
that especially with all the cut content
that has been riad 'add into the game of
all the mods on this list this one
probably feels the most like a
director's cut or remake of the game
which is kind of what I wanted instead
of a remaster so I'm really happy
everything is great except the addition
of this snake guy that guy sucked so
well done
grim rook on this incredible modded
experience though if you are gonna play
this one be warned it's tough so please
check it out or if you want more go and
watch my playthrough on Twitch before
the vaad gets deleted thank you for
watching